also
sind die eltern
plätze einzunehmen
liebe freunde
unserer gesellschaft für politisch
strategische studien kurz stratec
werte zuseher die sie uns an den
streaming empfangsgeräten zugeschaltet
sind
herr privatier und stellvertretender
kommandant alaba
querte damen und herren vize-präsidenten
und vorstandsmitglieder
soeben im rahmen der generalversammlung
bestätigt beziehungsweise neu gewählt
liebe angehörige unserer partnerverbände
freundes verwaltungsakademie sowie
gesellschaft für landesverteidigung und
sicherheitspolitik
kameradinnen und kameraden
ich begrüße besonders herzlich
der militär geschichtslehrer an der
theresianischen militärakademie
rovers des höhere militärfachlichen
dienstes
dr andreas steiger
[Applaus]
er hat sich überaus detailliert mit der
frage der landnahme des burgenlandes
1921 unter hundertjährigen geschichte
danach auseinander gesetzt
auf ihren sitzplätzen haben sie den
diesbezüglichen artikel aus der
österreichische militärischen
zeitschrift 6 20 21 vorgefunden den wir
bereits elektronisch mit zustimmung der
chefredaktion als beilage zur heutigen
einladung verteilen durften bitte nehmen
sie ihn mit mir noch bedarf an mehr
besteht es gibt noch einige exemplare
damit sie das ganze auch etwas nach
bereiten können
kobi 19 hat natürlich auch für das
vereinsleben und
unseren auftrag
als wär politischer verein und partner
des bundesheeres gravierende
auswirkungen
seit zwei jahren versuchen wir
zunächst aber mit geringer erfolg im
eigentlichen jubiläumsjahr 19 21 unsere
festveranstaltung zum thema 100 jahre
landnahme des burgenlandes durchzuführen
zunächst jedoch ohne erfolg
heute ist es nun endlich soweit und ich
möchte sie
alle ganz herzlich begrüßen und von ihre
für ihre teilnahme bedanken und danken
ich bedanke mich gleich zu beginn beim
stellvertretenden kommandanten der
landesverteidigungsakademie
brigadier magistrat schöberl für seine
immer gewährte unterstützung und
gastfreundschaft danke herr profitieren
[Applaus]
die größe ganz herzlich
einen guten alten im sinne von langen
kameraden nämlich herrn general in ruhe
hans löw
mit dem ich weit über ntc nie um das
vergnügen hatte
als leiter der operationsabteilung und
dann als leiter des führungsstabs
das burgenland betreffend zusammen aber
zusammenzuarbeiten
er war ja sehr lange stabs mitglied im
militärkommando und dann noch viel
länger militärkommandant des
burgenlandes und ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich dafür dass du im hintergrund
vielerlei ermöglicht hast was den
heutigen abend betriebs vielen dank hans
darf daran erinnern dass der general
auch
bereits eine zeitlang bundesminister für
landesverteidigung
in dieser republik gewesen ist
ich bedanke mich bei der harris bild und
film stelle für die technische
ausrichtung und bewährte regieführung
der heutigen streaming übertragung und
auch natürlich beim leiter der hbf
amtsdirektor regierungsrat günther
wilfinger sowie auch für die
unterstützung durch die medienstelle der
avag
ich bedanke mich bei allen mitgliedern
des vorstandes das tag für die teilnahme
am heutigen abend an der spitze
natürlich bei unserem ehrenpräsidenten
general karl mäzen
[Applaus]
das thema unseres heutigen vortragsabend
lautet also
jahre landnahme des burgenlands mit dem
untertitel an kraft und treue
eigentlich die jüngstes kind von
österreich
somit ist wie bereits erwähnt dafür
verantwortlich dass wir diesen festtag
erst nach 100 ein jahren aber genauso
herzlich begehen können
als vortragenden des heutigen abends
konnten wir mit dem landeshauptmann
außer dienst hans niessl einen wohl
ausgewiesenen fachmann und echten
burgenländer gewinnen hoch verehrter
herr landeshauptmann
ich möchte sie namens unserer
gesellschaft für politisch strategische
studien begrüßen und mich aufrichtig und
herzlich für ihre bereitschaft bedanken
auch unter den eingeschränkten
bestimmungen von profit und der
kurzfristigen vertretung des
verhinderten landeshauptmanns vom
burgenland zu diesem thema zu referieren
vielen herzlichen dank für ihr kommen
meine damen und herren begrüßen sie mit
einem großen applaus den festredner des
heutigen abends
landeshauptmann außer dienst hans niessl
[Applaus]
hans niessl wurde am 12 juni 1951 in
surendorf im burgenland geboren nach dem
besuch der volksschule in frauenkirchen
und der unterstufe am gymnasium in
eisenstadt absolvierte er
1971 die matura an einer htl in wien
danach studierte an der pädagogischen
akademie in der bundeshauptstadt die er
1973 erfolgreich abschloss im anschluss
daran leistete er seinen präsenzdienst
ab
anschließend war er als volksschullehrer
hauptschullehrer und hauptschuldirektor
tätig
von
1987 bis
2000 war er bürgermeister in franken von
1996 bis 2000 abgeordneter zum
burgenländischen landtag
von 2000 bis 2009 10 war hans niessl
landeshauptmann
des burgenlandes
hoch verehrter herr landeshauptmann wir
bieten von ihnen einen festvortrag über
100 jahre landes geschichte des
burgenlandes
mit seiner unglaublichen entwicklung von
einer art armen haus der ersten republik
zum prosperierenden blühenden und
zukunftsträchtigen
österreichischen bundesland
erwähnen möchte ich auch ganz zu beginn
den ersten einsatz des neuen
bundesheeres beim gefecht von
kirchschlag am 5 september
1921 gegen ungarische aufständische mit
zehn
gefallenen österreichischen soldaten bei
der verteidigung österreichs
meine damen und herren
ich bitte sie zum abspielen der
burgenländischen
landesvorsitzende zu erheben
[Musik]
bitte nehmen sie platz
möchte mich noch mal
bei general hans luif herzlich bedanken
denn auch dafür hat er die fäden gezogen
dass wir diese glaube ich sehr
stimmungsvolle aufführung der
burgenländischen
landeshauptmann konnten es ist dass die
aufführung der burgenländischen
landeshauptstadt name des burgenlandes
im kulturzentrum in burg schlaining
unter dem landes kapellmeister christian
kolonovits
und ich freue mich sehr dass er hans ich
bedanke mich bei dir dass du es möglich
gemacht hast dass wir diese
[Musik]
diese aufführung der landeshymne hier
zeigen durften das ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit und wir tun dies
nachdem die rechte beim land burgenland
liegen
mit freudiger genehmigung durch den
protokoll dienst des landes burgenland
herr landeshauptmann ich darf sie
nochmals herzlichst willkommen heißen
und darf sie ans rednerpult bieten
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr general
sehr geschätzte mitglieder des
österreichischen bundesheers der
landesverteidigungsakademie
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
am peter raab am heiderand du bist mein
teures burgenland war sozusagen der
schlosserei freiheit der hier dargeboten
wurde und das zeigt auch in diesen text
die vielfalt des burgenlandes vom
heiderand
bis am peter rabe im südlichen
burgenland mit der hügeligen landschaft
und das ist eigentlich etwas besonderes
dass das burgenland hat die vielfalt an
kulturen sprachen und die vielfalt der
landschaft
ich möchte ihnen auch zu beginn die
besten grüße unseres landeshauptmann
dass hans-peter durch kocin überbringen
der kurzfristig verhindert ist und
deswegen an dieser festveranstaltung
nicht teilnehmen kann ich habe über
seine suchen diese vertretung auch gerne
übernommen weil mich mit dem
österreichischen bundesheer
während meiner über 18 jährigen
tätigkeit als landeshauptmann aber auch
während meiner 13-jährigen tätigkeit als
bürgermeister der stadtgemeinde
frauenkirchen wo wir auch einige
angelobung
organisiert haben sehr viele positive
erinnerungen
verbinden und vor allem war es eine sehr
positive und gute zusammenarbeit die wir
traditionell im burgenland mit den
österreichischen bundesheer haben
pflegen und ich bin überzeugt natürlich
auch in zukunft haben werden und ist
auch darauf hinweisen dass ich in diesen
18 jahren sowohl mit den
militärkommandanten den damaligen
divisionär die aalener mit general läuft
oder auch mit gernot gaza immer wieder
im besten einvernehmen war
und wir einerseits natürlich was den
assistenzeinsatz betroffen hat
im burgenland sehr froh darüber waren
dass ist diese zusammenarbeit gegeben
hat dass es diese zusammenarbeit gibt
und dass gerade das österreichische
bundesheer bei diesen
assistenzleistungen
sehr sehr wichtige aufgaben für das
burgenland für österreich und
schlussendlich auch für die europäische
union erbracht hat
was für mich natürlich auch sehr positiv
in erinnerung ist
war auch die zusammenarbeit mit dem
damaligen
möchte ich die
nicht die gleich die burgenländischen
verteidigungsminister erwähnen sondern
auch mit günther platter nämlich eine
reform zu machen die ein oder andere
kaserne im burgenland zu schließen aber
auf der anderen seite kräftig in den
ausbau und die modernisierung von
kasernen zu investieren auch der
damalige
kommandant
general war zu dieser zeit im burgenland
tätig und sich da abzustimmen und zu
sagen was ist notwendig was ist der
standpunkt des burgenlandes das zu
arbeiten waren natürlich auch
interessante tätigkeiten wo wir glaube
ich ganz gute lösungen gefunden haben
jetzt verfolge ich natürlich wir haben
auch vor der veranstaltungen bisschen
gesprochen die aktuelle
politische situation in europa und
natürlich auch die diskussion wie werden
die herausforderungen die aufgaben des
österreichischen bundesheers überhaupt
die europäische sicherheitspolitik wie
wird sie gestaltet werden die
schwerpunkte sein und wird es
tatsächlich die notwendigen finanziellen
mittel geben geben müssen aus meiner
sicht um diese aufgaben auch in
entsprechender form erfüllen zu können
das war eine ganz kurze
darlegung eines standpunktes meiner
erinnerungen es geht heute um das
burgenland und ich glaube man sagt das
ohne übertreibung dass kaum ein
bundesland von kärnten abgesehen musste
um seinen anschluss in österreich so
kämpfen wie das burgenland
und ich meine jetzt nicht nur die toten
der landnahme des jahres 1921
seit dem vorjahr wissen wir jedoch die
namen und die herkunft der männer die
für das burgenland ihr leben ließen ob
es beim österreichischen bundesheer bei
der gendarmerie oder die als opfer von
willkür
und terror
das datenmaterial
verdanken wir der akribische
forschungsarbeit von ministerialrat
oberst magister martin seine kowitz
die kämpfe um das burgenlandes kosteten
auf österreichischer und ungarischer
seite
93 menschen leben auf
österreichischer seite sind insgesamt 63
opfer zu beklagen
13 damen kamen zu tode und 35 angehörige
des österreichischen bundesheeres
starten
besonders tragisch ist auch das
schicksal von 15 zivilisten die
ebenfalls zu tode kamen in einigen
fällen waren das regelrechte
hinrichtungen von zivilisten berisha
freischärler
auch ein bundeswehr soldat wurde
hingerichtet
der blutigste tag war der vierte
september
1921 an dem tag starben zehn soldaten
beim angriff ungarischer freischärler
auf die umgebung von kirchschlag
die ungarische seite verzeichnete 30
tote
bemerkenswert ist dass die freischärler
auch mehrere kameraden hinrichten wiesen
unter den toten ungarischen
freischärlern die aktiv mit waffen
gekämpft hatten standen nur drei aus
burgenländischen orten
während es auf der österreichischen
seite bundesheer zollwache und schon da
marie waren die die landnahme durch zu
führen hatten war die gruppe der
ungarischen gegner viel inhomogener
im burgenländischen
narrativ wurden diese gruppen unter dem
begriff freischärler zusammengefasst
ihre beweggründe
waren unterschiedlich
sie rekrutierten sich teils aus
studierenden der ungarischen
größtenteils budapester hochschulen ein
teil bestand aus ab gerüsteten
frontsoldaten der ehemaligen k & k
regimenter und ein guter teil setzte
sich auch aus söldnern und politischen
abenteurern zusammen
während die akademischen legionen der
überzeugung waren die heimat gegen den
feind von außen verteidigen zu müssen
gab es andere gruppen die die
restaurierung der habsburger zum ziel
hatten ein teil wurde ungarn vor den
kommunismus retten
heute weiß man dass all diese
gruppierungen von budapest gesteuert und
mit modernsten waffen ausgestattet
wurden ihre kommandanten waren partner
julius vom osten burg moravek und ivan
ergic sie nannten sich selber königlich
ungarische westungarische
aufständische aufständische auch der
bruder von franz lehar anton freiherr
von lehr mischte als militärischer
berater kaiser karls mit vereinzelt
kämpften auch ungarische reguläre
verbände an der seite der freischärler
sie hatten keine einheitliche uniformen
sondern sie trugen eine jagdbekleidung
auf den fotos die vorhanden sind ist
auch auffällig dass sie bis an die zähne
bewaffnet waren sie verfügten über
maschinengewehre und handgranaten und
waren damit weit besser ausgerüstet als
die österreichische galerie
über die anzahl gibt es nur schätzungen
sie reichen von 10.000 bis zu 40.000
heute geht man eher von einer zahl von
10.000 aus
die zeit der landnahme von 1919 bis
dezember 19 21 war für die später
burgenländische bevölkerung besonders
gefährlich von der bevölkerung waren
lediglich die vom ungarischen staat
eingesetzten beamten ein kleiner teil
des gebildeten bürgertums
teile des klerus und die
grossgrundbesitzer für den verbleib bei
ungarn
der überwiegende teil der bevölkerung
war für den anschluss an österreich
daher ließen sich die burgenländer auch
nicht für die freischärler einheiten
rekrutieren
während sich die freischärler als
freiheitskämpfer für großungarn sahen
war das bild bei der bevölkerung ein
anderes
sie errichteten in den dörfern und
städten terrorregime die bezeichnung als
banditen
dürfte noch schmeichelhaft für die von
der an der bevölkerung verübten
gräueltaten seien
wohl die ungarische regierung für den
sold und für die bezahlung der
freischärler aufkamen plünderten sie
behaupten sie die politische bevölkerung
sie misshandelten folterten und mordeten
und verbreiten angst und schrecken die
menschen des burgenlandes waren dem biss
auf die zähne bewaffneten freischärlern
hilflos ausgeliefert
da es sonst eigentlich keine autoritäten
im land gab
einen besonders tragischen fall möchte
ich hier als beispiel für viele andere
erwähnen und zwar ist das der fall von
josef esch
josef esch kam
1888 in ungarn jetzigen zur welt und in
sankt michael bei güssing war er als
notar tätig
gehörte eigentlich zur magyarischen dorf
oberschicht
er hätte die um acht jahre jüngere rosa
schied der zufall wollte es dass es
verwandtschaftliche beziehungen zu
staatskanzler renner gab
großer schwester luise war mit kanzlerin
verheiratet so dass elias der schwager
renners waren sich beiden von diversen
familienfesten und besuchen vom onkel
arena
persönlich gut kannten
am 28 august
1921 begann die österreichische
gendarmerie mit der landnahme
die ungarische an der marie und der
grenzschutz des bezirkes sammelt sich
daher im raum st michael und zog nach
ungarn ab nach dem abzug der österreich
besetzten sie sankt michael erneut also
sie sind wieder zurückgekommen und
ließen die deutschsprachige bevölkerung
die demütigung des abzuges auch spüren
und 30 august 19 21 wurde josef esch von
malte ungarischen damen verhaftet es
wurde im verrat vorgeworfen
als beweis diente ein privater brief von
seinen verwandten karl renner
darin äußerte er sich kritisch über das
verhalten der freischärler
der spionage verdacht wurde in den raum
gestellt
er wurde wiederholt verhört und von der
gendarmerie schlimm misshandelt
am 31 august wurde er von zwei damen im
wald zwischen kopten und kohfidisch mit
einem genickschuss exekutiert die beiden
mörder manche dame namens uhr kanzler
und e-bass und wurden im september 1923
vor ein ungarisches militärgericht
gestellt und
freigesprochen
das wichtigste
staatsrechtliche dokument für das
spätere burgenland wäre der vertrag von
st schon mal
1919 trafen sich in paris die
siegermächte des ersten weltkrieges
um mit den verursachern des großen
krieges frieden zu schließen sie hatten
aber auch den anspruch eine neue
weltordnung sehr schaffen und auf
grundlage von us präsident woodrow
wilsons idee der selbstbestimmung der
völker
für ein österreichisches deutsch west
ungarn gab es gute argumente
es war zum einen der großraum wien
der unmittelbar nach dem krieg aber auch
dann noch später zu einem hohen maß von
der landwirtschaft und viehzucht des
späteren burgenlandes abhängig war und
die bevölkerung war überwiegend
deutschsprachige
die hoffnung auf einen anschluss an
österreich waren groß
umso erschütternder war das erste
resultat der erste entwurf vom 2 juli
1919 der legt die staatsgrenze entlang
der alten staatsgrenze von 18 67 fest
das burgenland verblieb nach diesen
erstentwurf bei ungarn
erst in dem am 20 juli
übermittelte zweite vertragsentwurf ist
vermerkt dass das burgenland mit der
stadt oldenburg an österreich kommen
sollte
die anfang ging in ihrem zweiten entwurf
auf die von kanzler dr karl renner
eingebrachten argumentationen in bezug
auf das burgenland
weitestgehend ein mann nimmt an dass
dahinter eine intervention der usa auf
grundlage der forschungsergebnisse
zweier wissenschaftler standen
college und lorenz martin
nach dem bereits bekannten anschluss
verbot an deutschland und dem verlust
von böhmen mähren schlesien und auch
südtirol seit der vertrag gewaltige
reparationsleistungen vor
weitere vertragsbestandteile wann das
verbot eines allgemeinen heeres und die
rückkehr der kriegsgefangenen
weiters regelte der vertrag auch diverse
gesellschaftliche fragen wie zb die
freie religionsausübung
der verbleib weiter teile kärntens
sollte im zuge einer volksabstimmung
entschieden werden das ergebnis der im
oktober 1920 durchgeführten abstimmung
in kärnten wurde nicht in frage gestellt
trainer hatte sich für das
deutschsprachige west ungarn eine
volksabstimmung gewünscht er hoffte
damit die ihre dentist tischen
argumentationen ungarns jegliche
legitimierung zu entziehen da anzunehmen
war dass der großteil der circa 75%
deutschsprachigen und 15 prozent kroaten
für österreich optiert hätten
hätte es diese abstimmungs klausel im
vertrag von sascha merk gegeben während
die späteren kriegsähnlichen zustände
zwischen österreich und ungarn im zuge
der landnahme vielleicht nie passiert
dass
künftige burgenland fand in den artikel
27 und 29 seine erwähnung dort wurde in
wesentlichen zügen der grenzverlauf
zwischen österreich und ungarn
festgestellt mit dem schutz der
regionalen minderheiten im burgenland
setzten sich die artikel 66 bis 68
auseinander
für das auf einen kleinstaat
geschrumpfte und wirtschaftlich kaum
überlebensfähig österreich was für ein
schock man schöpft daraus aber neuen mut
für umgang an das ergebnis des
friedensvertrages von trianon 1920
einem staatspolitischen trauma gleich
man hat manchmal das gefühl dass ungarn
sich dieses trauma bis heute
nachwirkt ich denke nur daran dass
ungarn ein jahr bevor wir im burgenland
100 jahre burgenland gefeiert haben ein
jahr der trauer ausgerichtet hat und im
zentrum von budapest ein monumentales
trianon denkmal steht in dem alle für
ungarn verlor einen orte mit ihrer alten
ungarischen ortsbezeichnung vermerkt
sind
auch alle orte des burgenlandes sind in
diesem denkmal eingraviert der
unterricht name auch meiner
heimatgemeinde wo ich 13 jahre
bürgermeister war holocaust aus diesem
kollektiven schockzustand ist auch die
nationalistisch ihre denk tische
freisteller bewegung in ungarn zu
erklären
zeitgleich als ich in österreich die
erste republik konstituiert ist
das völkerrechtlich zur republik gehören
die burgenland mit seiner hauptstadt
oldenburg nach wie vor unbesetzt
der fünfundzwanzigste jänner 1921 an dem
das bundesverfassungsgesetz über die
stellung des burgenlandes als
selbständiges und gleichberechtigtes
land im bund beschlossen wurde
bundesgesetzblatt nummer 85 im jahr 1921
ist die offizielle geburtsstunde des
burgenlandes
nach dem offiziellen inkrafttreten von
trianon am 26 juli 19 21 beginnt am 28
august 19 21 der versuch der
inbesitznahme des burgenlandes der
sogenannten landnahme durch die republik
österreich
in elf kolonnen jede zur sicherheit von
einem offizier der alliierten angeführt
beginnt der versuch der besitznahme
hagendorf das ist ein vorort von sopron
sagt mal geräten pinkafeld und kofi
tisch kommt es zu kampfhandlungen
die landnahme durfte auf befehl der
alliierten nicht vom her
sondern musste durch an der marie kräfte
und zollwache durchgeführt werden diese
waren aber schlecht ausgerüstet und in
der unterzahl
mussten sich nach wenigen tagen aus
sicherheitsgründen zurückziehen
mittlerweile begannen die ungarische
verbände einen vorstoß auf
österreichisches territorium das jedoch
vom bundesheer gesichert war
am 15 september kam es bei kirchschlag
zu weitreichenden kampfhandlungen an
denen mehr als 400 soldaten beteiligt
waren
es grenzt an ein wunder dass dieses
gefecht nur das unter anführungszeichen
18 todesopfer gefordert hatte also eine
große anzahl
zehn österreicher ein zivilist innen
freischärler die kriegsähnlichen
zustände brachten auch die
nachbarstaaten von ungarn zu einigen
diskussionen
das interesse der sogenannten kleinen am
port bestehend aus der tschechoslowakei
rumänien und jugoslawien
lag in der eindämmung ungarns und dessen
gebiets forderungen gegenüber allen
nachbarstaaten im spätsommer 19 21 stand
zur disziplinierung ungarn sogar eine
militärische intervention der
tschechoslowakei im burgenland im raum
in dieser politisch und militärisch
aufgeheizten situation
schaltete sich italien als vermittler
ein in venedig trafen sich bundeskanzler
schober die vertreter ungarns kraft pln
und kraft bad bank und der italienische
aussenminister markise der terror in
venedig und verhandelte die friedliche
übergabe des burgenlandes
der vertrag sei auch vor für den
künftigen status von judenburg und der
umliegenden gemeinde eine eigene
volksabstimmung durchzuführen
die faktor hatte man sich aber in
venedig bereits auf den anschluss
altenburgs an ungarn geeinigt und
versuchte nur von der österreichischen
das gesicht nicht zu verlieren
das resultat der abstimmung von
oldenburg vom 14 bis 16 dezember 19 21
stand also von vornherein schon fest
die machenschaften der ungarischen
wahlbehörden sind in dem im
burgenländischen landesarchiv
vorliegenden dokumenten eindeutig
dokumentiert darin befinden sich
namenslisten von personen die es nicht
gibt und den straßen in oldenburg leben
die nicht existieren die machen
haushalten wurden tage vor der
abstimmung bis zu 20 personen neu
gemeldet und die wahlzettel sind rasch
verschwunden
der akzeptierte verlust
der gewachsenen hauptstadt oldenburg
sollte dem neuen bundesland
burgenland den notwendigen frieden für
seine künftige entwicklung sichern
die vielen deutsch und kroatisch
sprachigen in oldenburg und in den
umliegenden gemeinden wurden damit zum
gerechten staatsbürgern und die stadt
oldenburg erhielt den beinamen
sopron sie wie das fideles immer
sopron die teuerste stadt
eine offizielle hauptstadt erhielt das
burgenland
verfassungsrechtlich erst in den 80er
jahren
einen regierungssitz und sitz des
landtages beschloss der landtag bereits
im jahr 1925 also auch das hat einige
jahre gedauert dann konnte sich auch
über jetzt nicht gleich einigen das
erste stadt die landeshauptstadt sein
soll auch das diskussionen innerhalb des
bundes gegeben
vermutlich war man sich im jahr
1925 noch nicht ganz sicher ob dort
vielleicht doch noch den status als
hauptstadt des burgenlandes erhalten
könnte
ganz interessant ist auch die
veränderungen
direkt an der grenze zum beispiel in
luising das erst
1923 zu österreich gekommen ist
es hat also de facto zwei
friedensverträge und eine internationale
konferenz gebracht damit das burgenland
endlich ein teil österreichs werden
konnte die verträge von sascha meyer bzw
von trianon setzen die staatsgrenzen
zwischen den nachfolgestaaten österreich
und ungarn lediglich in sehr groben
zügen fest und ließen den beiden staaten
die möglichkeit den exakten grenzverlauf
im zuge einer von den alliierten
moderierten grenz kommission im
bilateralen
einverständnis selbst festzulegen
und wenn man grenzverlauf selbst
festzulegen hat dann kann man sich
vorstellen dass das meistens zu
konflikten führt das wird wahrscheinlich
vielfach im privaten bereich so sein
wenn man das selbst machen würde und ist
natürlich auch zwischen staaten
durchaus ein hitziger
diskussionspunkt
also
ende 19 21 hatten wir im burgenland zwar
endlich frieden
aber es war für viele gemeinden noch
immer nicht geklärt ob sie zu österreich
oder zu ungarn gehören würden es gab zu
diesem zeitpunkt rein deutschsprachige
orte
den umgang und mehrheitlich ungarische
in österreich im südburgenland kann man
daher im laufe des jahres
die im bezirk oberwart liegenden
gemeinden schachendorf
und parndorf sowie im bezirk güssing die
ortschaften oberbillig ein und unter
bild ein österreich
die letzte grenze korrektur erfolgte
durch die zuschreibung der gemeinde los
in österreich im jahr
1923 als using feiert das 100-jährige
jubiläum erst im jahr im nächsten jahr
der grenze regulierungs ausschuss
stellte am 19 dezember 1922 seine
tätigkeit ein
und am 10 jänner 19 23 km using
offiziell zu österreich
artikel 27 des vertrages von sascha
meyer schlug die deutschsprachige
gemeinde hagen store für österreich zu
während ebenfalls von deutschen
besiedelte gemeinde losing bei ungarn
bleiben sollte und das obwohl die beiden
gemeinden seit ewigen zeiten in einer
pfarre verbunden war
im sommer 1922 reisten die beiden
russinnen rudolf finger und thomas paul
nach altenburg und denn um bei der dort
residierenden
kommission die alliierten die
angliederung an österreich zu fordern
die behörde sagte eine behandlung des
problems
grundsätzlich zu
daraufhin fand sich die grenz kommission
am 20 august 1922 einem sonntag zu einem
nicht vor angekündigten lokalaugenschein
in luising 1
jeden sonntag befand sich auch an diesem
sonntag die deutschsprachige bevölkerung
von losing in der pfarrkirche von
hagens dorf beim gottesdienst
das wusste der ungarische gemeinde
notiert der nachbargemeinde been coming
cent und er hat entsprechend reagiert er
mobilisierte die ein wunderschön damen
und soldaten der ungarische
nachbargemeinde um die leerstehenden
häuser in deutschsprachigen losing mit
ungarischen national fahnen zu schmücken
und der hat die zustimmung für einen
verbleib bei ungarn zu suggerieren
einzig einige deutschsprachige durch
singer kinder waren noch im ort die zur
verteidigung der anführungszeichen
natürlich ihrer heimat die kommission
darüber aufklärten dass im ort
ausschließlich deutsch gesprochen wurde
es gelang den kindern das waren schon
eine größere kinder die abreise der
kommission so lange zu verzögern bis die
losinger bevölkerung vom hagen store
verkehr krank zurückgekehrt war
und die angaben der kinder auch
offiziell bestätigt wurde
manchmal schreibt der zufall geschichte
der weiß auch den jugendlichen kindern
von losing zu verdanken dass der
österreichisch ungarischen grenze
regierungsausschuss am 26 oktober 1922
lewis in österreich zugesprochen hat
es gibt im burgenland und das find ich
etwas schade nur wenige erinnerungsorte
an denen die opfer der kämpfe der
katamari und bundesheer gedacht wird
eine gedenktafel befand sich im landhaus
und später im neuen polizeigebäude in
eisenstadt
seit 2000 21 erinnert auch eine
gedenktafel am landes ehrenmal am
geschriebenstein der toten kameraden des
bundesheeres und am zentralfriedhof
befinden sich doch heute mehrere gräber
die von einer privatperson gepflegt
werden das land burgenland hat diesen
menschen sehr viel zu verdanken
es ist nicht nur bei kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen auf der fall
sondern auch im wirtschaftsbereich auch
im gesundheitsbereich
dass viele wenigen viel zu verdanken
haben und ich denke dass auch das
burgenland mit
knapp 300.000 einwohnern wenigen sehr
viel zu verdanken hat und das sind jene
die auch im jahr 1921 bei der landnahme
sich dafür eingesetzt haben dass das
burgenland zu österreich gekommen ist
und dass manche das auch mit dem leben
bezahlen mussten und daran sollten wir
gerade auch bei diesem besonderen
jubiläum 100 jahre burgenland heute
offiziell 101 jahren
gedenken und ich bin überzeugt davon
dass das burgenland jetzt und in zukunft
diesen personen auch ein ehrendes
angedenken bewahren wird danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
zunächst einmal vielen herzlichen dank
herr landeshauptmann für diese
so profunde
sachdienliche und detaillierte
schilderung dieses an sich etwas
sperrigen begriffs landnahme des
burgenlandes
worunter man sich ja im ersten moment
nicht sehr viel vorstellen kann
wenn man allerdings jetzt sich vorstellt
so wie sie das ja beschrieben haben
damit wie viele weit und blut das
verbindet verbunden war diese landnahme
des burgenlandes dann sieht man
das natürlich auch
die heimatliebe in diesem bundesland
ganz besonders ausgeprägt ist
weil dieses land wurde tatsächlich für
österreich erkämpft
ich hatte
die freude und die gelegenheit als
leiter der operationsabteilung
vom 5 september 1991
bis zum
beitritt ungarns
tschechiens zum schengen
regime
direkt die führungsverantwortung auf
militär militär strategischer und
operativer ebene
für den assistenzeinsatz im burgenland
zu tragen und
ich habe in diesen 17 jahren
einmal im monat zur dienstaufsicht den
assistenzeinsatz besucht und es gibt
glaube ich meines wissens nach
und vielleicht ein paar neue gebaut
worden aber kommen ein feld weg den ich
in diesen zeiträumen nicht selbst
abgefahren oder ab gegangen wäre
und es war schon in meiner zeit als
militär akademiker entweder 60er jahre
so dass ich mich sehr gerne im
burgenland aufgehalten habe und von der
von der offenen gastfreundlichen art der
burgenländer sehr angetan gewesen bin
das hat sich natürlich in diesen tagen
wochen monaten jahren des
assistenzeinsatzes noch erheblich
verstärkt
kann mich noch gut erinnern als
der damalige adjutant des herrn
bundesminister
damalige oberste des generalstabs
dienstes wolfgang spindler mich
angerufen hat nachdem der ministerrat
nach einer längeren diskussion
an diesem 5 september um 13 uhr 10
beschlossen hatte den assistenzeinsatz
zu genehmigen sind wir davon ausgegangen
dass dieser assistenzeinsatz zunächst
einmal zehn wochen dauern wird zehn
wochen zehn wochen
es war man darf nicht vergessen anfang
september vier wochen vor einer
nationalratswahl und daher natürlich
auch
eine gewisse
angespannte politische stimmung gegeben
ich kann mich noch gut erinnern
das damals von bestimmter politischer
seite
von einer partei die heute in der
regierung ist aber damals noch nicht in
der regierung war
sofort verfassungsrechtliche bedenken
geäußert wurden und der
verfassungsgerichtshof angerufen wurde
wegen der
legitimität dieses assistenzeinsatzes im
burgenland durch das bundesheer vor
allem die ausgestaltung dieses
assistenzeinsatzes und ich kann mich
noch sehr gut erinnern dass auch im
bundesheer in weiten kreisen des
bundesheeres
zunächst einmal
[Musik]
information und quellenstudium betrieben
werden musste und angeordnet werden
musste weil
die allgemeinen dienstvorschriften
genaue vorgaben für assistenzleistungen
ergeben
und hier ist es eben so dass die zivile
die zivile obrigkeit in dem fall die
bundesregierung
das den anfang des assistenzeinsatzes
das assistenz ziel und das ende des
assistenzeinsatzes vorgibt dass aber die
durchführung des assistenzeinsatzes
ausschließlich im militärischen händen
zu legen hat
und da gab's natürlich meinungen wie
auch was interessiert uns die atv das
ist doch eine vorschrift des bundes her
da mussten wir einigermaßen peinliche
gespräche führen und die anderen
behörden auch die obersten behörden
darauf hinweisen dass die allgemeinen
dienstvorschriften für das bundesheer
eine verordnung der bundesregierung
mit zustimmung des hauptausschusses im
nationalrat waren und sind
worin also sehr wohl auch allgemeines
verwandt verwaltungshandeln außerhalb
des bundesheeres generiert wurde
aber das hat sich dann mit der zeit
alles eingespielt und ich glaube ich
kann also mit mit großem stolz sagen
dass ich mich sehr gefreut habe dass ich
noch vom vorgänger des landeshauptmanns
in den 90er jahren als leiter der
operationsabteilung in anwesenheit des
damaligen bundespräsidenten gäste den
siegendorfer die weihnachtsfeiern
stattgefunden haben eine burgenländische
landesauszeichnung bekommen habe und
dann zu ende des assistenzeinsatzes
mit dem schengen beitritt von ungarn und
tschechien
musiker landes hat man mit dem höchsten
burgenländischen landesorden
ausgezeichnet wurde der auswahl meiner
vitrine immer einen besonderen platz
einnimmt und ich ihn immer mit großem
respekt und großer dankbarkeit an schaue
und mich erinnere was für eine ungeheure
zeitspanne
aus zehn wochen zu beginn am 15
september 1991 bis zum ende 2007 dann
geworden ist
meine damen und herren da herr
landeshauptmann war so freundlich und
hat sich bereit erklärt
auch für eine fragestunde und eine
diskussion zur verfügung zu stehen ich
darf sie ersuchen der hausordnung hier
entsprechend die masken auf den
sitzplätzen noch zu tragen wenn sie sich
zu wort melden bitte können sie die
maske natürlich abnehmen es wird ein
mikrofon träger zu ihnen kommen warten
sie bis das mikrofon da ist weil sonst
die
streaming zuhörer und zuseher die frage
die sich stelle nicht hören können weil
nicht im ganzen saal so mikrofonen
verteilt sind also bitte sich zu melden
und dann zu warten bis das mikrofon da
ist und die erste frage darf ich an so
vorstandsmitglied
brigadier manfred wagner geben bitte das
mikrofon zu ihm
dann haben das hat man ganz kurz wie
beurteilen sie die rolle des fürsten
esterhazy in der landnahme
man muss grundsätzlich sagen dass
die burgenländische bevölkerung
schon aufgrund der tatsache dass er 75
prozent in einem vortrag gesagt
deutschsprachig waren
15% kroatisch sprechend waren
dass es hier eine überwiegende mehrheit
gegeben hat dass das buch in ganz
österreich kommt und das hat ganz
allgemein in manchen bereichen des
großgrundbesitzers und auch des klerus
durchaus auch bestrebungen gegeben dass
das nicht zu österreich kommen soll und
ich habe diese auskunft auch von meinem
großvater bekommen der damals schon auch
politisch tätig war der
wahrscheinlich
ist nachvollziehbar auch sozialdemokrat
vor und die sich vehement für österreich
ausgesprochen haben aber es hat durchaus
auch in meiner heimatgemeinde in
frauenkirchen was grundstudium besitzer
anbelangt hat
durchaus tendenzen gegeben das zu
verhindern dass der spuk matches 3 kommt
also dass chance gegeben aber der
überwiegende teil war dafür
weitere fragen bitte herr botschafter
bitte das mikrofon
hat man da ist es wahnsinnig interessant
aus burgenländischer sicht jetzt zu
hören wie die landnahme damals von
statten ging aber auch die die
volksabstimmung sie erwähnten ein wort
das mich echt überrascht aber auch
neugierig machte nämlich sie sagten
österreich habe dann italien so zu einer
art von
schiedsrichter oder oder
helfer für die für diese politische
problematik gewählt jetzt es gibt eine
kleine eine tief verwurzelte überzeugung
in nicht
burgenländischen kreisen dass italien
bei dieser volksabstimmung
angeblich augen zudrückte und also in
großer zahl
ungarische soldaten und sonstiges nach
oldenburg hinein schleuste so ähnlich
wie
dieses ungetreue italien habe eigentlich
mit ungarn gemeinsame sache gemacht ist
das ein vielleicht eine eine mehr oder
können sich sowas
bestätigt wenn die zweite frage ist die
die tiroler kroaten
waren die automatisch aus bei der auf
der österreichischen seite ich kann mich
erinnern ich war vor einem jahr in
oldenburg
und da war gab es große schilder wo man
feierte diese abstimmung aber
auch die die abstimmung über den über
den teil der in
von der slowakei glaube ich
getrennt wurde und das geheißen wir
haben ja so viel propaganda gemacht wie
stimmt doch für uns ab denn dieses
armselige österreich ohnedies nicht
lebensfähig während wir wir in ungarn
für blühen also erscheint dass der
wirtschaftliche unterschied zwischen den
beiden staaten nicht unbedingt eine
einladung war das die deutschsprachigen
für österreich stimmten dankeschön
vielleicht
ist auch im vortrag gesagt habe ich auch
in meinen unterlagen stehen
dass man versucht hat eine friedliche
lösung zu finden
was grundsätzlich zu begrüßen ist
und deswegen haben sich in venedig eben
der bundeskanzler schober der
italienische außenminister
getroffen und haben über die
lösung gesprochen wie man das burgenland
entsprechend den friedensverträgen auch
österreich kommt und wie man das
friedlich machen kann und unsere
historiker im burgenland aufgrund der
unterlagen die im landesarchiv auch ein
zebra sind und in der kulturabteilung
die sagen und von dort stammen auch
meine unterlagen mit damit relativ
intensiv beschäftigt das vorher
ausgemacht war die freischärler ziehen
ab und an bord bleibt bei
umgang und kommt nicht zu österreich und
das war sozusagen im vorfeld agil und
die kampfhandlungen und das hat er doch
viele tote auch gegeben
ganz einfach zu beenden jetzt kann man
diskutieren ob der deal gut war aber
nicht gut war aber unsere historiker
behaupten dass das vorher ausgemacht war
dass die stimmzettel den weg waren das
auch dokumentiert in unseren archiven
der die wahlmanipulation feststellbar
ist also das
mehr oder weniger
durchaus akzeptiert worden seien auch
von österreichischer seite damit man
auch noch den schwierigen weltkrieg zu
einem frieden kommt und und und den
kompromiss schließt so
wäre meine interpretation
darf ich vielleicht noch kurz zu einer
anekdote
betreffend esterhazy kommen
nikolaus esterházy genannt der prächtige
einer der ganz großen magneten in ungarn
hat einen englischen landlord zu sich
eingeladen
am abend saß man also zu ehren des
gastes des landlord bei köstlichem
schottischen whisky
und der englische landlord hat er sogar
einen schluck genommen und hat zu
nikolaus esterházy gesagt
ich habe 5000 schafe auf meinen
ländereien
ist da es ja zunächst keine antwort
gegeben hat auch einen schluck genommen
und hat gesagt ich habe auch 5000
allerdings schafhirten
talent ist am nächsten morgen abgereist
fichtenbauer ich bin
100 1000 prozentig burgenländerin ich
komme aus neusiedl mein vater aus winden
und meine mutter wulkaprodersdorf
meine wurzeln sind aus meiner sicht
deutsche wurzeln allerdings meiner
kindheit habe ich sehr viel ungarisch
gehört noch von meinen großeltern
warum sage ich das weil es mir wirklich
großes anliegen ist dass alle hier
wissen und das nochmals wiederholt wird
von ihnen dass 75 prozent der
bevölkerung im burgenland
deutschsprachig war 19 21 warum sage ich
dass ich bin im laufe meines lebens
meinen ungarischen wurzeln nachgegangen
habe mir die höhe angetan ungarisch zu
lernen ich habe dann ungarisch er lernt
weil ich gehört habe als kind habe ich
mich nicht so schwer getan ich habe dann
ungarn kontakte geflogen ich waren der
universität in the present
viele ungarische kontakte und freunde
auf ungarisch kennengelernt vielleicht
ist das eine erweiterung des horizonts
weil auf ungarisch man sich vielleicht
anders dann unterhält wird deutsch
dadurch eine einsicht gewonnen und die
einsicht war das auch die heutigen
ungarn die heutigen ungarn
überzeugt davon sind
zumindest die ich kennengelernt habe und
das ist von der putzfrau bis zum
universität professor
burgenland ist ein teil ungarns sie sind
heute noch davon überzeugt dass die
mehrheit die mehrheit der burgenländer
ungarisch stämmige ist das wird doch
unterrichtet an den ungarischen schulen
ich da im blick hat er meine kinder
waren vielen ungarn sind viel kontakt
mit ungarischen kinder gehört das ist
ihnen auch immer so gesagt worden sie
meinen
tatsächlich also burgenland ist
ungarisch stämmige und zwar mit aller
vehemenz dass ich dann selbst gezweifelt
habe ich habe dann versucht zu
rekonstruieren
wie war das jetzt in meiner
heimatgemeinde wie war das neueste
weiterhin und caprice dafür war dass in
winten
21 19 21 ist er jetzt mehr ungarn oder
mehr deutsche oder wie war das jetzt
wirklich das ist nämlich nicht
selbstverständlich wenn sie das so sagen
75 prozent waren deutschsprachig und
ich hab dann versuchte die
kriegerdenkmäler zu lesen und weil die
toten aus dem ersten weltkrieg 1914 bis
1918 sind ja gestorben in einer zeit wo
ungarn wo burgenland noch teil um ganz
war und mit überraschung habe ich
festgestellt dass sämtliche verstorbenen
in neusiedl zum beispiel das
nordburgenland ja in neusiedl deutsche
namen gehabt haben kein einziger
ungarischer namen neusiedl kein einziger
ungarischer name in winden zum beispiel
und das obwohl dieser teil des
burgenlandes hunderte jahre vorher in
ungarn war für mich war das eine
überzeugende tatsache dass ich den
ungarn entgegen halten konnte nach so
war das aber nicht wir waren keine
ungarn wir waren deutschsprachig wir
waren überwiegend deutschsprachige dann
will es wirklich aus erfahrung erzählen
weil das so oft erlebt habe das argument
von den ungarn gesang zu mir zu mir
bitte als 90 österreicher ist
hundertprozentiger du kannst dir nicht
aussuchen wer du bist du bist nicht
österreicher du siehst aus wie ungarn
wissen jetzt ausschaut du sprichst wäre
hungen du bist ein teil von uns
mindestens bis zur leiter gehört das
burgenland immer noch zu ungarn das ist
eine kurze des schicksals dass es nicht
so ist
die geräte jetzt eben nicht von der
vergangenheit sondern von jetzt und
deswegen bin ich ihm so froh wirklich
froh dass sie als landeshauptmann und
sie sich auch jetzt noch berufen haben
auf historische unterlagen und das ist
die offensichtlich gibt mit vehement
sagen
burgenland war zu 75 prozent
deutschsprachig
ich nehme an zu 20 prozent oder 15
prozent kroatisch sprache und nur zu
einem ganz kleinen teil ungarisch
sprechen und noch als verstärkung dieser
theorie die ich sage ich rede auf
ungarisch mit den lehrern meiner kinder
mit den ungarn meiner kinder sind junge
leute die sagen wir wir waren ganz
überrascht wie wir noch ins burgenland
gekommen sind wie umgeklappt dagegen
alle ungarisch dann sag ich draufhabe
gewehr in neusiedl da gibt es keine
ungarn was heißt das sie sind so
unterrichtet worden sie sind diese
überzeugung ja nicht von der luft heraus
sondern weil das in ungarn so
dargestellt wird und viele andere dinge
universität der prozent wird
unterrichtet nicht nur sopron ist die
teuerste stadt sondern schon heute zu
hundert prozent aus ungarn bestanden
also nicht so wie sie jetzt gerade
gesagt haben sopron war überwiegend
deutschsprachige meine sei dank der
europäischen union ist das derzeit
überdeckt dieses thema aber
ich bin sehr froh dass es die dokumente
gibt und dass das auch öffentlich gesagt
wird um klarzustellen dass
boeing wird überwiegend durch sprache
gewesen ist und er zu österreich gehört
als 2 danke für mich
[Applaus]
weitere fragen bitte
bitte
ja zunächst herzlichen dank für diesen
interessanten vortrag meine frage
schließt sich in diesem bereich an wo
meine vorredner rennen gerade einen
beitrag geliefert hat neben der
überwiegenden deutschsprachigen
bevölkerung und der minderheit der
kroatisch sprachen gab es doch in der
minderheit an ungarisch sprachigen wie
war die einstellung dieser angriff
sprach im winter hat und warum ist es
dieser kleinen minderheit nicht gelungen
auf die ungarische seite zu wechseln war
die sprache das ausschlaggebende oder
doch das territoriale die grenzziehung
also man könnte in die geschichte
natürlich weiter noch weiter zurück
blenden
es gibt leute die haben einen stammbaum
der 117 jahrhundert zurückreicht und da
ist zum beispiel das große ansiedlungen
aus bayern im burgenland gegeben also
auch von der seite her das zweite ist
ich kann meinen großvater erinnern bin
bekanntlich auch nicht mehr der jüngste
wo ich schon gesagt habe dass die enden
20er jahren politisch tätig war und
vorher auch schon
und
kommen erinnern das sehr ungerecht
gesprochen hätte obwohl wir das muss ja
auch dazu sagen sie haben gemeinden
genannt wo überhaupt wenig ungarn waren
in frankieren haben wir etwas mehr
ungarn gehabt
und die crowd auf den gutschriften
teilweise
damals gearbeitet haben und dann später
erst von den gutshöfen da haben 400
leute auf gutshöfen albrechts feld
bauhof und so weiter gearbeitet die
damen die gemeinden reingekommen sind
es ist teilweise seien fehler gemacht
worden in der vergangenheit weil
grundsätzlich dass er lernen ob das
ungarische oder kroatisch ist etwas
positives ist ja jeder der mehr sprachen
kann das wissen heute forcieren das auch
immer sagen dass das land auch der bund
für diese vielfalt auch der volksgruppen
relativ doch einiges an geld zur
verfügung stellt und im kipp vom
kindergarten beginnen dort wo
volksgruppen sind auch die ungarische
oder die die kroatische sprache gelernt
wird man war teilweise der meinung
vorjahren was wird und teilweise auch
die volksgruppen was sollte nicht die
volksgruppen sprache reden unsere schon
kroatisch sondern deutsch ja damals
gesagt wenn du gut deutsch kannst dann
kannst den scherben beruf lernen wenn du
nicht gut deutsch kannst also lernt
nicht ungarisch kroatisch
dass ford die assimilation muss sagen
das war nicht unbedingt positiv weil wir
heute sagen jede sprache zu lernen ist
ein gewinn und man kann damit auch sie
entsprechend gut entwickeln also
insofern
was sie burgenland noch war das müssen
muss man auch sagen es
hat zwischen den volksgruppen kroatisch
ungarisch und deutsch eigentlich nie
probleme gegeben ja das war schon
irgendwo ein markenzeichen des
burgenlandes geschockt wie bürgermeister
war
die 13 jahren haben wir von novell wir
bisher größere ungarische volksgruppe
gehabt haben einen der ungarisch spricht
im gemeinderat und damit ist eine
entsprechende vertretung gibt es war
aber komplett problemlos der wahl
wahrscheinlich gar nicht drin weil es
ungerecht sprechend ist aber dass es hat
eigentlich nie besondere rolle spielt
oder bei mir im büro 18 jahre alt
landeshauptmann gesagt das ist ja quasi
das ist akkurat des osc kunst lukrativ
ist also insofern das ist für südtiroler
unverständlich es wird er tun weil da
bei mir einige male zu gast und der
gesagt also wenn wir wir haben wir sind
immer dem prozent zu fat arena und mehr
dürfen im öffentlichen dienst nicht
arbeiten wie dieser prozentsatz
cabrio her kann sich geändert haben wir
haben im burgenland nicht gesagt es gibt
13 prozent kroatisch sprechen die
bevölkerung unter 13 prozent dürfen dort
in der landesregierung oder im
öffentlichen bereich arbeiten sondern
der der geeignet ist weil wir dort damit
haben wir ganz entspannten umgang
miteinander gehabt und auch keine
probleme mit den ortstafeln und
englischen also im wesentlichen also
insofern glaube ist es im burgenland
eben
recht gut gelaufen dass
ob es vorher wie gesagt ich kann mich in
der kindheit erinnern
dass darum gericht gesprochen wurde oder
oder das dass die
probleme gegeben hat und wie gesagt ob
die ungarische volksgruppe der die
kroatische volksgruppe jetzt wird großer
wert gelegt dass dort wo gericht
gesprochen wird dass die kinder auch im
kindergarten tun können dass die quote
sprechenden auch schon im kindergarten
wenn sie wollen also kroatisch angeboten
wird und die mehrsprachigkeit glaube an
ein gewinn an und für sich je mehr
sprachen man kann umso besser ist es und
was man sprachen im kindesalter relativ
leichter erlernt dass sie im
fortgeschrittenen alter ich glaube es
auch eine bekannte tatsache dass
insofern war das durchaus im burgenland
so wie gesagt länder hat er vielleicht
gar nicht unrecht gehabt wenn das in den
staatsverträgen drinnen gewesen wäre
eine volksabstimmung
im gesamten burgenland zu machen dann
hätte es vielleicht die man das kann man
jetzt im nachhinein natürlich immer
klüger sein aber das ist auch schon
früher so analysiert worden es hat auch
in kärtner abstimmung gegeben und das im
burgenland wer vielleicht auch die
möglichkeit gewesen und bei der
landnahme tote zu verhindern wenn man
sich an die demokratischen regeln hält
wir haben glaube ich zwei anfragen
von streaming zuhörern haben wir heuer
darf ich bitten dass du die frage wie
man hört franz schreiber geschäftsführer
vorstellen das derart eck die zwei
fragen ich fange mit der zweiten an
inhaltlich basiert er gerade zur
thematik die frage wurde gestellt wie
ist das verhältnis zwischen der
gegenwärtigen burgenländischen
landesregierung und der ungarischen
regierung im kontext von vertrag von
tieren und damit gemeint eben der
verlust oder aus ungarischer sicht der
gedacht der verlust von land aber auch
als niederlage bezeichnet hat das
auswirkungen auf das land burgenland
zunächst spreche ich von meiner zeit und
und dann über die beurteilung der
jetzigen zeit
ich glaube es ist immer gut wenn man mit
den nachbarn gut auskommt und
ich habe versucht und ich glaube dass da
auch gemeinsam
in der regierung einiges gelungen ist
wenn wir das mal mit den nachbarn gut
auskommt und dass wir gemeinsam mit den
ungarn in
diesen
in diesen 18 jahren auch viele
grenzüberschreitende projekte gemeinsam
initiiert haben
und damit
dass er der bevölkerung zugute kommen
politiker und und grenzüberschreitend
zusammenarbeit zu überspringen und zwar
system menschen was bringen und es waren
wegen war auch immer meine vorgabe wir
halten von unserer seite immer guten
kontakt zu den umgang versuchen euro
eu-gelder für grenzüberschreitende
projekte zu bekommen und damit
bahnelektrifizierung
radwege grenzüberschreitende auszubauen
im bildungsbereich die sprache zu
forcieren und so weiter für für die
menschen etwas positives zu erreichen
und ich bin auch der überzeugung dass
auch jetzt aktuell versucht wird
unabhängig von dem denkmal und
unabhängig von der geschichte die es ist
ja alles schon sehr sehr 101 jahre her
das ist die geschichte des schon
erkennen geschichte ist sehr wichtig um
nicht vielleicht den einen oder anderen
fehler zu machen aber grundsätzlich hat
das burgenland nicht zu den volksgruppen
wo sie vorher gesagt habe sondern auch
zu den nachbarn ein wie ich fest
überzeugt bin ein sehr korrektes
verhältnis und die zusammenarbeit wird
auch mit den nachbarn gesucht
historischer frage was für eine
militärische infrastruktur wie in etwa
kasernen waren 1920 im burgenland
vorhanden vielleicht können wir dort den
obersten versteigert verrate also da
diese frage müssten fachleute
beantworten da fühle ich mich muss ich
ganz offen sein der general gesagt ich
war beim bundes aber das haben wir
eigentlich
so nicht mitbekommen also das wurde in
den vorträgen nicht mitgeteilt kannst du
was du sagen herr oberst
mikrofon
es war hier druck verhandler der pol bus
platz vorhanden es war die damalige
schul kaserne statt später ist martins
kaserne und benannt und im süden
völlig neue single habe natürlich
vergessen und im süden relativ wenig es
kommt die jägerkaserne overboard sogar
bei aus der bewegung 132 dazu es kommt
pinkafeld 19
32 dazu und
güssing
war auch noch geschichte und das wars
dann
franken gefährden ich darf vielleicht
nur ergänzen es wird deutlich mehr
kasernen gegeben damals was matura
führende schulen weil es halt im ganzen
burgenland nur eine matura führende
schulen ergeben jetzt wurde das
natürlich deutlich
umgedreht und wir haben dutzende matura
führende schulen im burgenland was auch
damit zusammenhängt um hier vielleicht
auch bislang brücke zu schlagen dass das
burgenland erstens das armenhaus
österreichs war das land der bildung
schande war das land der geringsten
einkommen war und mit schule mit der
bildung und wir haben viele jahre die
höchste maturanten quote aller
österreichischen bundesländer in der
vergangenheit gehabt mit den damit
weiterer folge mit den fachhochschulen
und so weiter das ist die basis immer
für eine positive entwicklung
gibt es noch eine frage bitte
bitte herr bringe dir
herr landeshauptmann sehr mich neugierig
gemacht was waren die alternativen als
landeshauptstadt zu reisen statt und
sind diese
alternativen heute noch aktuell
[Gelächter]
also frankieren wohl nicht im gespräch
ja es waren sauerbrunn war auch im
gespräch heißt da wurde auch diskutiert
das sauerbrunn landeshauptstadt werden
könnte es über mattersburg
diskutiert worden
das waren das sind durchaus auch
veranstaltungen organisiert worden wo
die entsprechenden städte informiert
haben warum sie landeshauptstadt werden
soll nach in eisenstadt hat
sorge wahlveranstaltungen gegeben wenn
man mal und führungs zeichen gesetzt das
heißt statt landeshauptmann hauptstadt
werden soll also insofern
waren mehrere standorte im gespräch und
wie gesagt ist die entscheidung auf ein
stück verein was natürlich wieder
schwierig ist weil wenn die geplante
hauptstadt eben nicht ins burgenland
kommt nur dann hat man wieder ein
gewisses vakuum da beginnt man zu
diskutieren und dann gibt es natürlich
viele die die ansprüche stellen oder die
ihre argumente ganz einfach vorbringen
noch eine streaming frage eine frage
noch aus dem live publikum und zwar
welche beziehungen pflegt das burgenland
zu den deutschen minderheiten im
heutigen test ungarn
die die deutschen investoren immer sagen
heute
die frage ist
dorf ist eine
eine deutschsprachige minderheit im
umgang und auch da gibt es verschiedene
kulturelle veranstaltungen immer wieder
einen austausch wie komme ich zurück
erinnern dass vertreter vorlagen dorf
auch im burgenland waren bei kulturellen
veranstaltungen also auch da gibt es
durchaus aktivitäten
gibt es noch fragen meine damen und
herren
wenn nicht dann darf ich die
diskussionsrunde beenden und darf mich
bei ihnen sehr geehrter landeshauptmann
vielmals bedanken dafür dass sie für das
heutige referat den festvortrag zur
verfügung gestanden sind und
unsere sichtweise
über das burgenland als
jüngstes kind von österreich
wesentlich erweitert haben ich bedanke
mich auch dass sich der nachfolgenden
diskussion und fragestunde gestellt
haben
und es bleibt mir jetzt nur noch bevor
ich
erinnerungsgeschenke an sie überreichen
darf sie darauf hinzuweisen dass wir
jetzt im anschluss daran bei den frisch
ungen wie ich das immer ne ne in fester
und flüssiger form heute die gäste des
burgenlandes sind wofür ich mich sehr
herzlich bedanken
[Applaus]
herr landeshauptmann dackel mehr
erlauben
zur erinnerung an den besuch beim
bundesheer der höchsten benutzer
forschungsstätte des zum bisher in
ramsberg akademie innern ein neues buch
über das bundesheer als und republik zu
überreichen ich habe mir erlaubt
eine widmung für sie hinein zu schweren
und vielleicht kann es ja mal zeit fürs
training zu schmücken es ist in erster
linie ein bildrand
[Applaus]
es ist sehr schwierig im landeshauptmann
vom burgenland einen wein zu überreichen
aber vielleicht können wir einmal gut
oder hand erfahren wo bei ihnen gemeldet
hat
[Applaus]
bitte begeben sich hinaus und genießen
sie burgenländischen schwanken